every radio definitely has its own
personality
this is the boombox your grandmother or
maybe your great-grandmother would have
carried around this reminds me of
football actually if you live in a
split-level house this is the radio for
you
[Music]
this radio has never been opened before
this one's a breeze there's not a whole
lot of documentation
that's still around on how to do this
it was glowing too red for my liking
you get them in wrong the radio blows up
sometimes i work on these radios for
hours and hours and hours and just when
i think i'm about to give up something
clicks in my mind
and it works
to me this radio looks very science
fiction
like this would be like the the console
of a spaceship
it started off as a hobby and now it's
become
a little bit more than that
i have several hundred at any given
point
these radios are found in dumps and
garages and old closets
there were families that probably sat
around these radios and listened to the
first man land on the moon
fdr's fireside chats were probably
playing through these
[Music]
radios digital technology sterilizes
music
old radios sound a lot more organic
a lot warmer
when i repair these radios i feel like
i'm giving them back their old voice
[Music]